they said that if they stayed in that
camp they would be killed there and
things escalated very quickly and it was
at that point that the guards started to
panic what these women were telling us
was very very important what you're
being told needs to be documented so you
keep filming this is a huge smuggling
Enterprise in a country where the state
has broken
so the economic incentive for the
Libyans who take part is huge
but because it is a massive criminal
enterprise because life is cheap there's
no real reason that anybody is going to
put you on a boat tall beard a broken
boat that may very well sink as soon as
it gets offshore it certainly won't get
to Europe the migrants and the smugglers
work on the premise that the people will
get picked up in the Mediterranean but
some people they don't even get that far
[Music]
it's a real challenge working in Libya
when you're there as a journalist the
first impression you get is there's not
much of a structure here it's somewhat
of a freefall it's quite hard getting
things set up getting access we're
constantly being pushed back giving
false information at times and being led
down blind alleys
[Music]
Libya is under enormous amounts of
political pressure from the European
Union
so the Libyans are keen to show that
they are dealing with the problem that
they acknowledge themselves that they
don't have the money to deal with it
they don't have the tools to deal with
it so they'll take you and show you the
conditions that people are living in
once we spoke to say that they are doing
their best to treat these people in a
dignified and humane manner but when you
look inside those detention centers they
are anything but humane or dignified it
was a really desperate scene the
temperature inside those places is
stifling and it's horrendous
whatever you think of the migrant crisis
and whether all these people should have
made the journey to Europe in the first
place nobody should have to live like
this
conditions in here are absolutely dismal
it smells suffocatingly hot more than
200 people in here and between them
there's only one bathroom in a room full
that so much despair as long as I'm in
focus this story just sort of tells
itself I pretty much just have to hit
record
we films during mealtime
we were told by the migrants so this is
the only meal they got people who ran
the detention centre said that they were
actually fed a number of times they're
given food in an enormous bowl it's the
sort of thing you'd feed animals with
their suffering they're lethargic
because they're not getting enough to
eat many of them are sick how difficult
is it to look after all these people
very very very very difficult they are
trying to go to Europe
we're keeping them safe to return to
their countries and you've been given
help from Europe now not as much as we
need your must Bluebird and help us Alex
and Jake were able to start peeling off
and speaking to people without anyone
listening in it was a case of
distracting one of the wardens they saw
us as a window to speak to the world the
minute you start to speak to these
people one on one you start to hear
nothing but desperation because
apparently you know we see brilliance
falling falling down we can even help
them everyday things get worse most of
the people we spoke to said that they
were not being well treated they were
being violated and abused routinely
this is frozen so three those like
pyramid you were surrounded by the
sights and smell of people who were
desperate people who had nowhere to go
people who had no idea where their life
was going and where they would end up
what will you do now what happens you
know you we spoke to a large number of
migrants who would tell us these stories
of how they were abused how they were
beaten and the I'm doing as I'll say to
walk when were walking do not be us
so they're taking you're putting into
work yes everyday daily even our - we
have some people's our absence they are
died their life he doesn't know they are
talking outside
when they are commenting here you
treated as slaves yes they were targeted
by malicious and then taken to these
detention centers because they were
worth money as slaves these people like
enemy
we didn't get any we didn't take money
first um nah we didn't do any crime yes
we are Rafi Eitan come across see here
there are Eszterhas from the minute they
leave home to the point of getting to
live here trying to get to Europe they
are in constant risk of exploitation the
men and women in this detention centre
are separated so we walked into the
women's quarters but it didn't look like
great conditions through here
there were beds there were places where
they could sit you didn't get the sense
that it was awful things were quite calm
to begin with what happened they were
three sisters and some other women in
the group
Alex was sat down started to ask them
questions and it was almost immediately
where do you come from I'm from Nigeria
and they just started to break down I'm
fed up fed o-p-s or I try to escape you
tried to escape yeah no I mean they
catch me back on I was treated badly
what happened what did they do they told
me not only me they accused the people
in the camp of beating them as you can
see is because we are treated badly a
artist Larry tried to escape
her friends and something will have
family members started to show us where
they claimed to have been beaten it was
totally surprising but also really very
affecting the guards interpretation of
events was that nearby there is some
military facilities that the woman had
tried to escape and run into and when
they were caught running into this zone
they were then detained and manhandled
and that's where the bruises in them and
the marks had come from that's not what
the women had said they said that if
they stayed in that camp there would be
killed
the mood had quickly changed as soon as
they started telling us their side of
the story the authorities in the guards
who are with us very quickly got quite
angry and things escalated very quickly
and it was at that point that the guards
I think started to panic they wanted us
to end the interview we wanted to
continue with the interview and clearly
what these women were telling us was
very very important we needed to hear it
what you're being told needs to be
documented so you keep filming whilst
they were arguing with Alex I was able
to move to another corner I need
[Music]
I needed more pictures before we got out
of there so that we could actually tell
the story if any one of these there was
a point where the guards tried to call
their bluff and said to them well if he
was so upset if you're so distraught
than leave this group of women didn't
know what to do they knew that this was
part of a game they also knew that they
actually had no way of getting anywhere
they had no money they had no support
they had no one who could help them take
them there knew no idea where they were
necessarily and how to get home and what
was home
okay
[Music]
I started looking like I was filming but
I didn't see the need and actually
switching the camera off it's become
increasingly common now that when you're
filming sensitive situations around
authority types in countries like Libya
you are often told to stop filming or
don't film that mm Nora
you know forbidden you can't film that
so you have to try and find ways between
yourselves as a team of still trying to
get those images they're very important
[Music]
we kept rolling so we saw kind of the
dynamic between these groups of people
the women clearly very very scared the
men running the detention center worried
about what this would mean for them if
their bosses saw that this had happened
and wanted us out of there they wanted
us to take them from the center and get
them out of there that of course you
can't you're powerless you go in there
you hear their story but that story
doesn't end just because you've left the
libyans say that they will eventually be
repatriated and sent back to their
country of origin but you don't know
what will happen to them I think that's
the fate that probably faces many
thousands of people who are in those
kinds of detention centers men and women
we need to I think sometimes reflect the
risks that they're taking in full
knowledge of what the consequences could
be imprisonment abuse exploitation even
death that they're still willing to take
those risks because of how difficult
life is in the countries that they are
coming from and unless you address it
from that perspective I think it's very
unlikely that people's attitudes are
going to change and things will get
better
as long as there is the pull of Europe
and as long as migrants sink them there
is a hope of getting and Libya is a
chaotic place there will always be this
criminal enterprise than these smuggling
gangs so the problem will always
continue
you